a father-and-son day-out brought to an
abrupt end officers investigating a
stabbing handcuffed Andrew Boateng and
arrest his son Hugo he is 13 and both
innocent well I just kept shout enough
stop that's my son
he's only 13 stop that's my son again it
was all inaudible at the time because
the officers of course we didn't know
that officers at that time sort of came
with kind of high aggression levels and
those loads of shouting researcher so I
was fearing he was at first being mugged
Hugo ran into the undergrowth which
scarred his face but it was what
happened next which frightened him the
most I didn't know it was officer until
he pulled out his taser he was aiming
that at me and he threatened to shoot it
shoot me if I moved I felt really scared
and worried
Andrews worried about the long-term
effects on his son for the two nights
after the incident he slept in his
parents room afterwards I was really
worried about that going out on my own
if that happens again after that I've
been more aware although when whenever I
hear sirens or um see police go past the
officers were responding to a stabbing
in the nearby park and said that both
father and son matched the description
of their suspects black males for those
campaigning for fairer policing it's all
too familiar the police and Criminal
Evidence Act says that officers need to
have reasonable grounds to carry out
their duties now in this case I don't
believe the officers had reasonable
grounds to suspect those particular two
people were doing anything wrong what
needs to happen is that officers need to
be aware that they have powers and they
can they can be abused so in order for
them not to be abused they need to
provide a service that's professional
courteous and is is one that doesn't
leave people feeling traumatized
the Metropolitan Police has made a
voluntary referral to the independent
office for police conduct for them to
assess the incident in a statement they
say two senior officers have visited the
individuals concerned to speak with them
so he can learn from this particular
incident we are keen to maximize any
learning that comes from this the police
want incidents like this stamped out but
this family is shaken and the impact
could be long-lasting ash Najarian a
great stylist